the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so we began just a few months
ago you know with this goal which I
understand the scientific study of human
nature how our mind operates why we
behave the way we do from the brain
basis how we see and hear the world how
we think how we feel our predispositions
to act in certain ways how we developed
from infancy to adolescence to adulthood
through the Middle Ages and into old age
we all hope the remarkably odd things
about human social interactions which
are just amazing I think and the
challenge is that so many people face
with a degree of vulnerability in these
very kinds of abilities and behaviors
and so it's hard to know you know so
what to conclude on so I thought I would
touch on two things one sort of fun to
think about hard to know how to think
about scientifically and one you know
probably matters to us all the time
so let me talk about this so when we
think about why we do things how our
brain is organ as I mind is organized we
know that we've evolved over a long
period of time from other species and
that many things in us reflect this
evolutionary history you know cast into
a modern unimaginable world from the
viewpoint of biology right but here we
are you know sort of creatures from the
past living in an incredibly accelerated
changing environment and so evolutionary
psychology people say let's try to
identify why we have certain patterns of
thoughts and feelings given the history
of our you know the evolutionary history
of our minds and brains and I'll say a
word about that it's tough in many ways
though to have a stroke as much as you
believe that's truth gotta be true very
tough to approach scientifically because
often it comes down to people telling
fun interesting clever stories right
very hard to test so we know it's a big
part of who we are in a deep sense where
we came from very hard to test
experimentally I'll show you a couple of
examples where people have probed this a
bit and then another question is in the
last decade some people have said well
so much a psychology seems to focus on
the negative the harm were willing to do
the stereotypes were willing to hold
how about positive psychology how about
thinking about what can we learn from
psychology to lead a better happier more
meaningful life and so I'm going to tell
you about the sort of core results uh
about research about happiness and some
of them I think will surprise you you
know some of them will tuck in the back
of your mind maybe as you think about
what will make you happy I mean we all
want to be happy in a deep sense you
know we we don't know what's on the
other side of this life but we know this
is the one we have in our hands and so
you know what what can psychology
suggest that might make you think what's
a path to happiness so we talked to
throughout this course about the fragile
power of the human brain
it endowed us with a unbelievable
capacity for thought psyche behavior
vulnerabilities at every stage from
neurological injuries to
neuropsychiatric disorders and again we
know this all has grown through this
Paul MacLean triune brain idea that
within us are kind of a version of
reptilian brains within us our simple
mammalian brains and then finally the
primate and human expanded neocortex and
that so within us it's almost as if we
represent in a certain sense our species
history literally in your brain
literally right now in some complex way
of interactions but you departure the
brain that have evolved modestly and
parts that have involved spectacularly
in humans so you know and the usual
story and you're used to this and
evolution is that our brains and minds
evolved in nature and the natural
selection was a huge you know the
dominating part of the story survival of
the fittest for passing genes into the
next generation that sort of all stories
boil down to that I'm going to tell you
two specific examples I want one that
surprised me and then one that's just
sort of fun I think in a silly way so so
the first one is attitudes towards race
and sex and this came up and the second
one is different attitudes when men and
women that who might have in terms of
sex and procreation so let me focus on
this for a moment in the last election
you may remember that there was a long
grueling race across the primaries
between Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama
and in many ways this is a huge surprise
in the United States because we're such
a history of racism and sexism the idea
that the two leading candidates are a
woman and an african-american right
which is kind of an amazing thing that
we you know as much as we have distance
to go that we've come that far that
these were the two candidates on the
Democratic side who were you know
competing state to state across the
country one of whom will become the
Democratic nominee and the president ah
and I got a call from a reporter from
The Boston Globe said he was writing a
story saying which is the worst problem
these candidates face sexism or racism
all right and many of us and I'm I'm no
exception our egos get turned up when
somebody from the press calls because
you know our name will be the newspaper
we can show it to our friends and family
and there yeah and then they know we
have a real job and somebody thinks we
know somethin right yeah you laugh I'm
the graduate students you know like the
note the parents never understand
anything except when their name gets in
the newspaper right you know how that is
right okay so so I thought well I'm
gonna say something really clever and
all the neuroscience I know and all the
psychology I know either from my own
researcher for teaching this course I
was something I just had nothing to say
I mean you know we can all agree that
racism has been sexism is bad it's kind
of a you know excellent that candidates
are you know beating those glass
ceilings and in national leadership we
know from research on things like the
IAT test so you heard about that both
remain a problem negative stereotypes of
certain kinds remain in our society to
this day across society so but I had I
was like you know which is worse
terrible thing a or terrible thing be
right and I had nothing to say and then
a newspaper article came out and said oh
according to evolutionary psychologists
and I was not included because I had
nothing to say right it was very sad I
said they said well really Hillary
Clinton faces the harder path because in
their mind sexism is built into our
species because the whole idea of how we
procreate how men and women relate in
species and investment right that's deep
in us all through evolution wears racism
is culturally specific and malleable you
know there's countries where one group
is picked on this country's where
another group is picked on there's
changes in societies that's that's a
changeable thing you know this is a
tougher thing to change was their
interpretation I thought well that
sounds good might even be true it's like
a lot of evolutionary psychology a good
possibility a better answer by
infinitely far that I could give but who
knows and then there's one study came
out that's kind of curious so this is a
study of children with Williams syndrome
a rare disorder but very studied in both
Jeannette human genetics and human
psychology and it's partly it's
interesting these are the unusual facial
features of these kinds of children
they're born this way and it's caused by
a deletion of 26 genes from the long arm
of chromosome 7 it's one of the most
purely defined and specific genetic
developmental disorder disorders in
humans so it's really drawn the
interests of Genesis because a disorder
that's really very linked to a very
specific part of the human genome always
distinctive what they call elfin facial
features developmentally delayed
language skills and maybe the most
curious and charming element is
unusually cheerful demeanor and ease
with stranger these are the children who
will walk up to strangers and talk your
ear off and not be afraid of anybody on
anything okay you know tuning to an
extent that's you know charming can get
you in trouble
with the world being the way it is but
they are at the if there's a sometimes
their contrast with autism so
individuals with autism find social
interactions sometimes laborious
difficult mysterious these individuals
find it delightful non-stop you get
tired sometimes I've talking to such
children because they're ready to go you
know infinitely in terms of social
interaction and there's been some study
they did a typical amygdala function and
lack of fear response there so that's
the background about Williams syndrome
and then somebody did a IAT study this
is in France but it's been replicated
since that shows that for these children
Williams syndrome they still have a
gender IAT effect that is for example
they're willing to consider women less
likely to be good at science and math
which we know is silly but that's a
stereotype okay
but they show no racial IOT effect and
they had control participants who show
both so now there's still interpretation
but all of a sudden it's as if this is
deeper in the brain and maybe this is
learned and these children aren't
learning this one but they can't stop
this one that man all right so a
suggestion that there is some something
true about this evolutionary psychology
thing and that may be the hardest thing
for us to change deep down because of
the fundamental of sexual relations in
procreation that's a hard thing for us
to work our head around without without
being thoughtful and careful about it
so here's an experiment that was used to
demonstrate so what's the usual story
you know the usual story evolution is
people on average not everybody of
course wants to have kids because I say
they pass their genes down and who who
has a lot of investment per kid in
however way you look at it women right
you know from women it's just just the
first part is nine months okay and then
the immediate support for men how long
is a minimal contribution 15 seconds
okay okay 15 minutes and it varies but
you know you know you okay so so there's
a theory that if you only think you
cared about right was just getting us
your genes down there as much as
possible
was it Wilt Chamberlain the former
basketball player who said he had slept
with a thousand women you know that he
would be like the the you know the
champion example and then and with women
it's there's you can't do a thousand
nine month cycles okay so that for men
if that was the only thing in life and
it's not but but here's the experiment
they did we couldn't have an IRB approve
this but this was done at a university
and they said we're gonna show you an
experiment like this and and this is
meant to be kind of silly but this is
how evolutionary psychology things are
expressed and it's kind of funny I think
so what they would do is they would pick
an attractive man an attractive woman
they were the Confederates and they
would approach a student leaving the
library random student okay and here's
the respondent he's a woman imagine
yourself as women now for those of you
who women leaving a library you know
kind of late at night not too
threatening but somebody walks up to you
and says you know I've noticed you in
the liar
a few times you seem very nice do you
think there's a chance we could get
together for a date sometime what
percentage of women said yes in this
study 50 percent okay had anything
that's high okay let's say was it let's
pretend it was a better approach than
what I just I tried to make it low-key
and nice a low-key nice approach okay
same for other women the same male
Confederate walks up and says I've
notion library seemed very nice
what do you think Mike going back to my
apartment and having a some coffee
what do you okay well take turns on
women what do you think is the number if
we start with 50 what 20 all right I've
noticed you in the library you seem very
nice I think you know there's something
compatible between us would you what do
you think about going back to my
apartment having sex right now see
finally the course gets super practical
right okay okay
I'm not saying it's right this is just
this one study right
all right now we reverse the roles that
man you get ready all right all right
attractive woman walks up to you says
I've noticed you in the library you seem
very friendly we've seem to be
compatible would you be willing to have
a date with me sometime would you be
willing the woman says to the man to go
back to my apartment with me right now
all right you know what is going
practive woman walks up to the manling
where he says would you go back right in
that time Hartman have sex with me this
very minute Jackson the guy's got things
to do you know again yeah
you know what is the citation for this
let me get that I heard it that talk I
saw the numbers and numbers are correct
there's a there was I have to say when
this was presented there was some
murmuring because maybe it wasn't quite
irb-approved
I heard it from a good source I'll get
that for you okay it's in your notes and
it's it's okay all right so evolutionary
psychology whatever it's kind of fun but
you know it's hard to know where it gets
you but it's definitely fun to talk
about all right so uh happiness research
so you know for a long time you know
from ancient philosophy to founding of
the u.s. everything people said the
objective of life as we choose it
Aristotle for itself and never for any
other reason one of the most amazing
phrases in the Declaration of
Independence we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable I fan
Liberty well that we would think would
be obvious things now right but this
amazing thing and the pursuit of
happiness you know as important as life
itself and Liberty itself the pursuit of
happiness and I think we know that in
our own lives as we were late to other
people as we pursue careers as we do it
things whatever where we put our limited
lifetime resources time and effort we
want we don't want to end up in a deep
way to be happy and make the choices to
get there so we can think on average
what are the kinds that you could think
in your head what makes you happy what
makes you unhappy and you know a
standard list might be it's you know
people definitely want to be healthy
nobody minds being wealthy you know you
could talk about that it never hurts to
get a new car a new TV or new stuff
right what makes you unhappy physical
injury emotional injury I mean you know
that would be kind of standard now how
do you measure happiness alright and
this is the part where you get to into
the funniness of psychology see you have
with you a questionnaire which is one of
the most widely used measures of
happiness so I'll just give you a moment
to look at it you can fill it out for
yourself and we're not going to collect
it just to you know or again you may not
even want to or whatever but just to get
a feeling of this and you could say oh
yes sir anybody else who didn't get it
that we could help you with okay a few
hands over here
again let me say whoever did this
amazing display is made me super happy
so you're ahead of me okay thank you so
um so it's measuring with that you ask
the person like basically how happy are
you right and and we have a tendency to
be suspicious of just asking people
straight on because if we asked them
straight on you know would you say this
line is as big as this line if three
other people said they'd say no not me
right if you say would you snap somebody
you know so that you think they're dead
in another room you'd say no not me
right so so we're very suspicious about
what people say they will do and what
they really do but for happiness
research it's hard to beat that here's
another one you can circle the happiness
that represents you okay because what's
the better question what's the more
objective measure to decide that
somebody's happy a brain image a blood
test we don't have a better thing than
the person's own statement about their
sense of happiness all the way back to a
Roman philosopher the happy man is not
he who seems thus to others but who
seems thus to himself you know we don't
know if a better way to ask you if
you're happy than to ask you if you're
happy okay so it's not the most
satisfying kind of objective scientific
measure but maybe it's the life we lead
anyway right we decide if we're happy or
not in some sense so if you ask people
on average how happy they are you know a
lot you know two-thirds of the people
will put themselves here almost
everybody above the average few people
report that they're consistently unhappy
and I'm gonna come back to this but the
thing that has struck happiness
researchers surprisingly modest
influences and I'm going to touch this
up a little bit with recent study of
social status income gender or ethnicity
a number of things that you could have
thought would touch that surprisingly
don't touch it or in very limited ways
but I'll tell you a little bit about
those limited ways Senate seven-point
scale the average is four or five
college students four point nine older
people happier we've talked about that
before ironically even the older people
probably face
challenges in various ways and limited
lifespans they see them happier by
self-report
one argument that income has little
relationship is this kind of a graph
that looks at the average income in the
US from 1930 to 1991 so here's this
increase that's not going up anymore but
it was in the last century and
self-reported happiness and you could
see that at some point it goes up but
then it flattens out so it's the general
thought and I'll show you a little bit
more detail is you know not much money
or in current situations poverty you
know does strike down people's sense of
happiness but once you get above some
threshold and of course what that
threshold is varies in so many ways
depending on who you are and what you
expect but once you get above some
threshold that's not the biggest part of
the story anymore and that's pretty much
a general finding they've done all kinds
of surveys about happiness across
countries it's a really interesting
thing about happiness research it's more
powerful than you can imagine and
grabbing hold of the minds of many
people in public policy Derek Bok the
former president of Harvard has written
a book suggesting that happiness
research ought to be the basis of public
policies by the government that if you
know what makes people happy
what you know short of giving everybody
a million dollars every year why
wouldn't you tweak every policy - even
if people don't think it will make them
happy but you know from research it will
and then what's here's a world map where
they survey people all over the place
the darker the color the more people
reported themselves happy now this is
very tricky right because now you're in
the full scale there's things like
poverty but there's also things like
cultural emphases right in the US we
talk a lot about happiness that concept
is less prevalent in many other cultures
relatively speaking so it's hard to know
how much is the culture how much is the
actual per capita income relevant but
people are pursuing these things and
they are finding roughly this approach
the most recent one that
in countries where there's a lot of
poverty it's less in countries where you
start to have higher income so you know
poverty is still associated with less
happiness and you can guess that is
reasonable and and the more studies like
this again about that direction so early
on people said that I mean that people
you know that income is nothing to do
with happiness and that seems not quite
right especially at the lower end of
poverty now Dan Kahneman the Nobel
laureate psychologist at Princeton has
spent the last years talking about what
he calls a focusing illusion and let me
tell you what that is it's basically
this when thinking about one topic could
be income could be graduate school
admissions like whatever the topic is
fairness and whatever the topic is when
you're thinking about the one topic
people tend to attribute more importance
to that topic than it really has they
think it accounts for more of what goes
on in the world when they're focused on
it and you see this all the time in
political discussions like it's all the
deficit right we just fix it if I said
everything works there's all raising
taxes if we just do that people fixate
on one thing and then that's the answer
to the whole problem that all the time
never mind political debates you know
where things might be staged but even in
one's own personal life that happens let
me give you an example of how they show
that to be true they have people rate
the happiness just like you had and then
they ask them and these were how many
dates for the single people how many
dates in the last month and they get no
correlation between self-rated happiness
and how many dates you've had in the
last month
now they reverse for some people the
order of questions how many dates have
you had in the last month and now rate
your happiness and they get a positive
correlation the more dates you had the
happier you report yourself well for
people who are dating on average that's
a measure like getting out there meeting
people you know it's an average of
succeeding in some paths you want to be
on so when you just thought about this
he said whoa if I had no dates this past
month I must be pretty miserable I'm
pretty unhappy I'm thinking about that
right and all the other elements of your
life that contribute to happiness
because you just focused on that you
just focus on that because the question
was asked recede disparate
fortunately compared to the actual
importance if you go the other way
around half a PR and you ask this
there's no correlation right because
you're just answered you're not thinking
about this one thing and weighting your
overall happiness by this one question
or dimension does that make sense
okay so heat this is the order is the
whole story it's that we're that people
when they think about a topic and then
think of how happy or meaningful it is
they over value that topic because they
just focused in their minds on this one
dimension so getting back to this issue
of income and how gat goes with
happiness here's what they did the same
thing again by asking a specific
question and asking your general
impression the same idea so they said
how was your mood how bad was your mood
the previous day so there's a specific
question about mood now how much time do
you think people with various income
levels are in a bad mood and they pick
for example people making less than
$20,000 or people making more than 100
these people who just answer this
question said gee I don't see anything
thank you very much
yeah a cool thing is you know they're
making videos of these lectures you're
gonna we have so many applicants to be
your peers and the years to come it's
gonna be unbelievable all right so you
guys are great all right so so they said
it was about 32% more bad mood if you
were making less or more if you asked
people making how much it's only a 12%
difference it matters but only 1/3 as
much right because you just got them
thinking about being a bad mood so now
they over attribute income for daily
happiness and here's a kind of
interesting thing and it's a trade-off
and it gets us to what is it in your
life that makes you happy so here's a
people making over a hundred thousand
spend about 20 percent more time on high
thank you this reversed okay so people
making over hundred thousand spend more
time I'll fix this light up sorry spend
more time on doing things that they
report is being kind of stressful work
you know pressured shopping for the
family pressure childcare situations
what they call Bluebird Tori tasks and
people who make less money spend
considerably more time doing things that
everybody considers fun when they're
doing it socializing or watching TV that
you like okay so you can see it's kind
of weird it's a little bit of you know
where you put your time and what counts
for you to feel happy about something
everybody is in pretty much agreement
that like you've heard about almost
everything twin studies suggests the set
point of happiness whether you write
yourself is always super happy
moderately happy or somewhat grumpy
seems to be about between 50 and 80%
heritable so it's as if a piece of us is
born to be super happy medium happy or
chronically grumpy okay
there's not a better or worse way to be
it right okay so that people will call
this a set point so of course things
happen on a day to day basis on a
moment-to-moment basis that push you up
or down and happiness of course you'll
get good news you get bad news you're
fearful things joyful things coming up
but the idea is that people tend to get
back pretty fast to the set point their
level
whatever that is of chronic constant
happiness and if this is kind of an
amazing finding so let's take a look at
that and add one more point
so here's extroverts by personality
measures and introverts and extroverts
report themselves as being happier says
that's a setpoint example a personality
thing that seems to go over time but
they share the bumpiness of the week
here's how happy they are in Monday
Tuesday Wednesday whoa a weekend
approaching and the misery of Sunday
when the weekend is over so so as you
can see in both things of course they're
responding to the workweek cycle of you
know heavy work anticipation of the
weekend the weekend itself and
anticipation of the you know work day
right
both groups do but this the set point
seem to be a little bit different the
chronic constant level now there's been
a bunch of ideas about whether a
question about whether people can be too
happy can a person be too happy you know
and here's what they find that if they
hit take people who say I'm super super
super happy and you ask them what's
going on in their life that makes them
super super happy
those people often report that it's
close relations to other people and
often good deeds or volunteer work is
the thing that's making them super super
happy a little less happy on average but
still pretty happy are people who are
have higher incomes higher education and
more political participation okay all
right so look at these two things you
can say in your own life as you know
that mean Bo all these things will
matter but you know which is the model
of success for you and your heart you
know the human relations and doing good
or this sort of income education active
in your world thing it's not one is
better than the other something you have
to choose one or the other but it seems
like people will tend to focus more on
one of the all these things are matter
okay but you know where you put your
heart it's easier or you end up doing
this if you're on the most extensive
happy so you know maybe if you want
somebody to do a certain thing for you
don't want to be so happy they had to be
a little bit grumbly about stuff right
if you
think the world is perfect you're not
going to fight for political change okay
so what makes us happy and it turns out
in interesting ways there's it's more
complicated than you think
and so it's worth thinking about because
your first intuitions might not pan out
so here's an example but I want to tell
you this I'll remind you once again and
then switch to an everyday one so one
part of happiness is that when we
reconstruct what made us happy what made
us happy growing up as a child what made
us happy as an adolescent in high school
was happy last year last month last week
that's all out of memory that's not the
current moment of joy or frustration
that's your sense of what was it all
about what you know where was I in terms
of happiness and so Kahneman again to
this work with looking at pain reading
pain ratings during a dental procedure
and you said what determines your memory
for how painful it was and the two
values were the peak of the pain and the
ending intensity so that if you added a
little extra pain at the end people
actually rated the whole session in
memory as less painful okay you add some
mild pain at the end rated as painful
okay but because it was mild because the
last number that goes in their algorithm
in their mind he is the strength at the
end and the other number seems to be the
peak he could predict pretty well how
you would rate the painfulness of the
entire session so this shows you that in
many ways our minds construct our
definitions of happiness they're not
simply our sensory experience and here's
the thing you could think about for a
moment you know you so many of you have
had jobs or something you haven't had
most of you a long work period and a
consistent basis most of you I'm
guessing but think about how are you
happier at work or vacation so if you
ask most people are you happier at work
or vacation most people will say
vacation that's why I work 50 or 51
weeks of the year to have that awesome
vacation right okay if they do a study
where you carry a beeper on you and they
beep you every once in a while
unexpectedly and say
one two seven how happy are you and some
days you're at the office and some days
you're on your vacation what happens you
report yourself happier at work okay on
average of course so that's amazing
right why do we have vacations at all
not to be miserable right yeah I mean
could you mention an ad and said like
you know come to our hotel you'll be as
less miserable than another hotel on
your vacation right Evelyn we're great
so so what do you think's going on here
well what's going on here's the
interpretation this is that finding
what's going on here the interpretation
is when we think ahead about a vacation
or when we reconstructed in our mind
there's some things about it that make
us like it a lot
when we're on the vacation and you may
know this and I think part of it it's
the anticipation of vacation sometimes
what happens hotel wasn't so good you
got that food poisoning that ruined the
whole trip your brother or sister we're
really a nuisance your parents were a
drag your parents can't understand why
you were so salty like you didn't have
the space to separate out and get
yourself you know all sorted out is it
okay that I'm not yeah you can I had
that too it's like a kid I mean
sometimes you sort of whatever a little
conflict see at home seems to get
exaggerated when you're jammed in
together for long periods in cars or
rooms or tents or whatever and and then
you go back home in a couple of weeks
ago man that was an awesome vacation
I'll never forget it it means so much to
me
and it's not that you're faking it you
really feel that otherwise he wouldn't
get ready for the next vacation the next
year okay so what this suggests is in
ourselves really there's at least two
ways or two minds thinking about
happiness one is a moment-to-moment
happiness that's real and one is a sort
of big picture what was my life about
okay and I feel like my life about is
going to interesting places with people
I care about that's a vacation so you
know it's not that one is not that
people are hypocritical is that in them
there's these different dimensions of
happiness that are tapped by different
moments of thought happiness researchers
their most controversial topic because
they can explain almost everything in
the story I just told you
his children so I you know you talked to
parents and over 33 percent will say the
single people you know over the single
biggest thing that's the joy in their
life is being having children or
grandchildren that's a very common thing
you could say your surprises not more
okay but still it's a lot it's a single
biggest thing and I think people really
mostly believe believe that and when
they say that if you have people keep a
day-to-day diary the moment-to-moment
source of happiness and they rate one to
seven everything they just did so it's
kind of fresh in their memory okay
childcare is rated just over housework
below sex socializing with friends
watching TV praying eating and cooking
okay because again it's this weirdness
of like you know oh he's not doing his
homework err we're afraid she's doing
something or you know or little kids
they're just running around not doing
what you asked them to do and it's so
frustrating because you can't get it
yeah so moment to moment so happiness
teachers don't understand what people
have children at all they can't explain
it okay there's a lot of effort going on
to come up with some formula okay and
again it's not that people tell you oh
we can't believe we have kids but how
stupid was that you know they say and
they feel you know it's it's a
phenomenal source of happiness for them
it's just when you ask them how about
five minutes ago they go no why did he
talk that way what is it he or she
listened to me why don't they clean the
room ever their twenty five years old
they can make their bed or whatever
I'm truly interesting these two
different dimensions of happiness so
this idea that there's within us there's
multiple selves the moment-to-moment
self that's real the big picture what is
my life about that's real they're not
always perfectly aligned in the US and
moment to moment happiness in a recent
study increases until about seventy five
thousand of course that's an average
different depending on what you need to
buy that number will move but then it
tops out on average but the big picture
emotional well-being on but overall
satisfaction keeps going up with income
now
have to be very careful in the season
they're all correlations everything I
told you just about as a correlation
right so when you say overall
satisfaction so a big picture sense of
life goes up with income is it really
the income what else could it be
is it literally the size of your
paycheck does it have to be that yeah it
might be the kind of job you're doing on
average and we know there's phenomenally
important jobs that are underpaid in
this country okay we know that but
there's a lot of jobs that are kind of
fun to have that are decently paid okay
you know doctors lawyers scientists you
know a lot of people find those jobs to
be pretty fulfilling and pretty decently
paid and there's other ones as well okay
all kinds of jobs are decently paid that
can be fulfilling so it's not
necessarily that it's just about
literally the if you know three more
dollars in your three-dot more dollars
happy right
so these correlations are very tricky
but again the sense that moment to
moment tops out somewhere here you know
well above poverty but then big picture
keeps going up somewhat so think for a
moment if you can just for a moment
think about yourselves 5 or 10 years
from now and when you think of it if you
can just for a moment to specifically
imagine your mind what you might be
doing five or 10 years from now and pull
your hand up if your thought of
something pretty positive
I hope okay put your hand up now if you
thought of something kind of negative
some of you go boy okay most people our
roots claim they think about positive
things in the future other than fumbling
or failing so how good our people are
predicting what will make them happy how
good our people are predicting what will
make them happy what people call
effective forecasting so I'll give you
two examples you know one that's closer
to my life and one that might apply to
everybody actually I'll tell you a word
about this that's a funny story if I so
if I don't get tenure I will be sad if I
get tenure I will be happy so you know
what tenure basically is you're given a
position in a faculty position for a
lifetime unless you do something really
right okay so you can't be fired no
matter how no matter what you do almost
okay another freedom from that so on the
other hand what happens if you don't get
tenure somewhere do you know what
happens it's not so pleasant I could
tell you it's not the end of the world
at all but let me just tell you what you
know going in what you know going in is
your colleagues are gonna meet they're
gonna vote they're gonna say no which
kind of hurts cuz you've been there five
or six years right okay and then you
have to leave town okay you don't have
to leave town that could be another
university nearby but usually because
we're so super specialized in our fields
you have to leave town okay and go
somewhere else and you have to tell your
parents I didn't get tenure if you tell
your friends I didn't get tenure and all
your friends who you know from work oh
I'm sorry you didn't get tenure for a
year everybody you meet with goes I'm
sorry you didn't get tenure so so you
just don't want that right okay well you
know it's a moment I mean none of us why
so everybody says I'd rather get tenure
than not okay would you rather win the
lottery then not sure okay um
happiness researchers love these things
so it turns out that for a couple years
after you don't get tenure and all the
negativity and leaving town and getting
another job and by the way some people
have not gotten tenure and become
amazing superstars so the tenure process
is often incorrect in its evaluation but
two years later no difference in
happiness at all it doesn't really
matter in the long run winning the
lottery a year or two later no
difference either there's a whole
research field that runs out the minute
somebody wins a big lottery and I had a
bit of experience on this other than the
ratings somebody working in my brother's
house one the single largest lottery at
that time prize ever for a individual
lottery winner in the United States it's
been exceeded since it was something
like 187 million and she was definitely
pretty happy and she's she done she's
been I have to say remarkably wise since
then you know she and how she's used the
money I've been a very stable person
kind of but there's equal number of
stories of people who get into huge
trouble
actually the most amazing story i sort
of silly to share but i think i've been
relatively short lecture so there this
was in the news because you know how
with a lottery they say whoever wins
this will win the single water so
there's a huge number of tickets sold
and some guy a taxi driver at the
airport because all the news outlets
wanted to cover this and they were
looking who won and they knew that there
was a winner they didn't know who it was
and somebody a taxi driver the airport
supposedly said I won the lottery I won
the lottery okay now we knew he didn't
because we knew this person had won it
okay but all the news chat channels were
running after this person because other
cab drivers thought he said that and
then apparently all the people he owed
money to were hunting him down and he
got and he had to hire a lawyer to sort
of fight off people and so he was really
miserable and it was sort of a sad weird
thing to be the lottery winner who
didn't get the lottery right but
everybody thought you did
and there's other stories in towns these
are amazing stories of you follow you
know where they know somebody want the
lottery in the town but the person
doesn't have to come forward and and
then you get all this weird stuff
because other people start to guess who
really has a ton of money amongst them
okay and they have wrong guesses and
they go and say well you know my mother
needs medical surgery won't you help me
and the person doesn't have the money or
maybe that one does but most don't
there's only one and so the whole town
gets into huge fights and misery because
they are assuming that somebody could do
amazing things for everybody but they're
just being mean and not doing it right
and 90% of their guesses are who that is
wrong I'm sorry more than you want know
about lottery but I can tell you that an
average a year to later no difference so
it's amazing you would think that would
make my life if I won the lottery and
probably it does in terms of plasma TVs
but in terms of self-rated happiness no
difference and here's a know more
amazing thing in a certain way although
if you talk to patients not as amazing
if you have a unexpected accident
leading to quadriplegia or paraplegia so
you really can't get around return to
typical ratings of happiness in three
months so we're incredibly unable to
predict because we would have all kinds
of ideas about how long these would
Buddha lies our sense of happiness and
we're wrong wrong wrong we don't know
how to predict what will make us
and so people call this hedonic
adaptation that we said or their set
point that you go back your set point
over an incredible range you do respond
but you go back to it of an incredible
range of life outcomes so there's a
small experiment compared to these
things but a controlled experiment dan
Gilbert Harvard who's done amazing work
in this area get Harvard students in a
photography class choose their two
favorite pictures from the entire class
and they were told they have to give one
to the teacher and they can keep one and
there were two conditions in one
condition
once they gave that picture to their
teacher that was it and the other
condition they could change the picture
that they could change the picture in a
few days now now you know in all this
course every time you think a go
opposite be right because that's but if
you weren't amazingly sophisticated
psychologists at this point if you were
just a person on the street what you
think would sound better having no
choice or having the possibility of
exchanging the picture if you want to in
a couple of days the choice we like
choice right no the people who are
happier are the people who say once you
hand the picture that's to me these
people are staring like I don't know I
don't know what would I be happier this
picture that picture I don't know I
don't know I can't write because also
once it's an irrevocable choice what's
what what amazing human thing comes into
play that helps us feel good about our
lives cognitive dissonance did I pick
the right picture that teachers a sucker
I thought they were above the two best
but the one that teacher took oh that
was pretty bad I can't believe how lucky
I am that irrevocably tied it up with
this picture right the person who has
days to do this they can't let cognitive
dissonance come in and fix up their
choice paradox of choice you know why
choices can be painful so again we like
choice I like choice there's an
experiment and you know people say you
go into a typical big grocery store or
285 cookie choices 13 sports drinks 75
iced teas 200 channels and more right on
cable okay so they did an experiment in
Palo Alto a Stanford group in a gourmet
food store and they the exotic high
quality jams and you could taste some
jams and then get a coupon for a dollar
off if you buy the jam
so take a couple kind of thing you might
see sometimes in grocery stores and they
would have you taste either six jams or
up to 24 now most people didn't do 24
jams okay because you wouldn't want to
have that in any even single taste of a
jam but you'll try a few right at the
table like this
so so first of all here's the two tables
six jams are 24 more shoppers came to
the table of 24 well you see 24 jams out
there it's kind of impressive right like
there's got to be something I like there
what's going on right so more people are
drawn to the big choice Department now
when they get there they only have about
five jams these people have about six so
it's about the same number of jams that
you taste big display lots of choice
limited choice what happens in your
actual behavior well if the six Jam
table 30% of the people purchased the
gym if there's a 24 Jam table only 3%
made their purchases so what do you
think happened we don't know for sure
this is the actual behavior exactly the
opposite more choices among jams led to
less purchases of jams
what do you what's your guess as to what
happened yeah they were in a jam yes and
and because what because because I tried
five or six that's all I could try but
there's another 20 out there and they
could be awesome beyond belief and I'm
not gonna come in okay because it could
be something awesome Jam around the
corner and I've only tried five or six
right so they're overwhelmed and instead
of happily getting a jam they're jammed
up as you say I think oh well who can
begin to figure out what's the right Jam
for me it's just way too big right so
all those choices make them less likely
to make a purchase than this exactly the
opposite of what might intuitively too
many choices ours are burdensome all
right and you might some things are big
but you know calling plants I don't know
if you've ever tried to compare calling
plans across phone services but you know
you you sit down for a few moments and
you just give up I thought maybe you
don't okay health insurance thinks
retirement plans you just get all these
complicated menus and a lot of people
just give up and they don't go like
what's the cheapest or what's the what
most people do okay the Morgan because
it's just too hard to figure out so when
they do Paul when they do surveys
of asking people what people think will
make them happy
these are the most common answers if I
get into a relationship or a marriage
that I like if I have more flexibility
at work of getting a baby if you if
that's what you want losing weight cure
of a chronic disease making more money
having more time advancing in beauty
okay this is the list it's not a not
surprising list right what would make
you more happy and again we know that
happiness set points are about 50
percent 10 percent estimated a
circumstances like poverty you know
things that you can't help in your life
just can't help but happiness
researchers are trying to make the case
that about 40 percent of our happiness
depends on what we choose to do so
that's a big piece ok it's a big piece
you know we can't help some things in
our genes or in our global environment
but this is almost half and these are
estimates maybe it's more but this is
the current estimate and research you
know over and over again you know shows
that it's wrong to think that a
happiness is found like you get there
and Here I am happy that it's in
changing in your circumstances I move in
a city I get a promotion I meet another
person that's the happiness and that you
either have it or you don't I'm just a
person who's not happy all these things
the objective evidence is against and
what here's what researchers find goes
with in experiments and in correlations
you know here's their list by from as
objective evidence as they can get in
this kind of work time nurturing
relations with family and friends comes
out as a number one thing that plays out
expressing gratitude in helping others
whole experiments where if you just did
something nice people feel awesome so
I've heard I heard at Berkeley
psychologists say just try to feel
unhappy after you just expressed
gratitude or help somebody and you can't
even do it
ok I don't know if that's quite true but
experiments have shown that when you
have people express gratitude or do
something to help others their happiness
ratings go zoom right up practicing
optimism about the future savoring life
in the present physical exercise
commitment to lifelong goals
ambitions you know a sense that you have
a path that makes sense to you right as
opposed to bumping around for
opportunity and opportunity and
something about having an approach to
coping or resilience when bad things
happen I mean I'm sure in some of your
lives heartbreaking bad things that
happened most of us get some of them
many of us get everyday things that we
struggle with and the path by which we
deal with adversity huge influence on
self-reported happiness so again so this
is a my final slide and I hope that you
know this course me you guys some you
guys have made me happy throughout this
course I've had incredibly pleasurable
lunches and dinners and brunches with
students from the course I this is just
stunning for me it's really moving and
I'm just very grateful to have had the
chance to introduce you to these ideas I
have a okay exam period you have to get
through that it bounced back and cope
and have a great summer thanks very much
you
you